hey what's going on my name is Alan
dragu and today we are doing Q&A that's
right we're going to have some fun I
asked you guys on Twitter I still call
it Twitter I just can't with the X I
don't know just it's called Twitter all
right you guys uh ask me questions about
copywriting email marketing and just my
personal life which is great I mean
that's super fun so we're going to dive
into the questions today let's go ahead
and jump in actually before we jump in
if you want you can go ahead and hit the
like like button to like this video And
subscribe to the channel if you want
more content on email copyrighting email
marketing things like that let's dive in
all right let's do it all right Mar
hieta or Marcus hieta nen I hope I said
that right asked the question great I
love how you start with that here's mine
what is the best way to grow an audience
on X okay if I were you and I were
starting out again here's what I would
do is I would choose a niche one Niche
okay like mine's email copywriting and I
would find all the people in my Niche
that I want to get to know or build
relationships with and then I would
create a custom list with those people
and add them to the list like I have a
custom list on Twitter called
copywriters and I add copywriters that I
like to that list and then every day I
scroll that list instead of the timeline
and I reply to them and I build
relationships with them and I send DMs
to them and I comment on their stuff and
and laugh and we play and have all stuff
and so now I have a bunch of friends in
that space which is Propel me cuz now we
all just help each other if I post
something they comment cuz they're
friends now and and if they post
something I comment and it's all about
relationships build a list of very
specific people in a very specific Niche
get to know them you guys will grow
together don't over complicate okay
that's it next question from Richard
pazinski
zinski okay what is something that you
have learned recently that you have
started applying in your business my
reply to that is I would spend more time
curating the people in your life
including business including friendships
including everything I would curate
highly curate the people in your life
honestly especially business because
when you work in business you work 30 to
40 hours a week okay if you're Average
Joe you're working 30 to 40 hours a week
and that means you're spending that time
with colleagues with customers with your
supervisor with your employees right you
have a whole hemisphere of people that
you're working with and if you don't
like who you're working with that sucks
man and and life is too short to sit
here work 40 hours a week with Donna in
accounting cuz Donna's a douchebag no
offense Donna actually tons of offense
if you're a douchebag get out of here
all right next question uh Arian akari
how do you monetize
copyrighting um how do you not monetize
copyright I'm not going to lie me like
it's copyrighting right uh the best
definition of copywriting I read in like
a bob blly book or something where he
talks about copywriting is just a
Salesman behind a typewriter that's it
everything copywriting does is selling
okay so either you're selling on a sales
page or you're selling your own products
via email or you're selling anything
else that you do on billboard whatever
it is Google ads everything copyrighting
does is selling so either you should get
a percentage of those sales or you
should charge for your riding time okay
but it is the most monetizable skill on
the planet but I hope that helps anyway
my man one JD media Biz ask beehive or
convert kit convert kit all day long
super easy um and the reason I I've had
both and they're both good but convert
kit is great couple reasons number one
reason is convert kids deliverability
right I've seen more beehive newsletters
laying in the promotions and spam tab
than almost any other platform and
that's cuz they have all the like
embedded media and I don't know what
else they have in there but it lands in
the spam and so the deliverability of
convert kit I've Just Seen to be so much
better other things like the automations
and the laning forms are way easier to
create and connect and convert kit which
is awesome uh convert Commerce having
the the ability to create products and
convert kit and then plug that to your
email list inside and it's one cohesive
sale that goes to your St it's just
integrated better and it's all the
things that you need not to mention
they're a much bigger company who's been
established for a lot longer of a time
which usually comes with less bugs lot
better support stability in the growth
all those things convert K hands down
next question all right Milos
wbec Phantom what does that mean by the
way I don't know what that means what is
your biggest challenge you're facing
right now if inappropriate shoot me a DM
I would saying my biggest challenge that
I'm facing right now is uh what I would
consider quiet ambition finding a
healthy balance between like enjoying
life and peace and relationships and
those things and just being a highly
ambitious person that wants to create
content write emails and shoot videos
and and create cool products and all
those things like my tension between my
ambition and my uh joy and peace for
life they often butt heads and so that's
still something I'm trying to figure out
if you have any advice for that man feel
free to drop something in the comments
below I'm enjoying life and all those
things but you get it so yeah that one
Amit Kumar asks best copyrighting book
of all time in your opinion and what's
the best way to get more email Subs okay
that's two questions in one let's answer
the first one best copyrighting book of
all time I don't think there is one book
that's like this is the go in fact if
you are getting into the copywriter
space or you are a copywriter and you're
not willing to read like a lot of
copyrighting books multiple times I
don't even think you should be in the
space if I'm being honest I I genuinely
don't if you're not willing to commit to
six to 10 books reading them five to six
times right that's how much it takes to
really get into that mindset but if I
were to recommend some books let me
recommend a few scientific advertising
by Claude Hopkins this is a really good
to get into the door of copyrighting all
the fundamentals okay next one is
infotainment Jackpot by Ben settle this
is a pricey one I'm not going to lie
okay this is a really pricey one but it
really Blends the world of entertainment
and information so that way you can
really build relationships and sell a
lot of stuff so that's a really good one
goat mode with ad week copyrighting
handbook Joe Sugarman this is like all
the fundamentals right I will not lie it
is a little bit of a boring read it's
kind of dry um but he's got some good
stories in there too that that kind of
spice it up and he's got all the
fundamentals but it's a mustre boron
letters a lot of people talk about this
book some people really hate it some
people really like it I I think it's an
absolute fundamental you got to read
this one and then the copywriters
handbook by Robert blly this is this is
a freaking practical book okay he talks
about internet marketing he talks about
direct advertising he talks about
copyright writing in every different
facet really practical talks about
headlines subject hook all that stuff
just really really good one Ogie on
Advertising okay this probably is one of
my favorites if not my favorite because
I really love David Ogie and he's he was
just a character of a guy just nuts all
over the place and so I really like
reading his just escapades and and crazy
eccm around the world I mean he's just
this is a really good read and then
lastly uh breakthrough advertising again
a very pricey book generalistic but all
these books make you a lot more money
than you pay for them so really really
fun and then an honorable mention not
really a copyrighting book but it is
right the king of Madison Avenue it's
David uh OG's autobiography it's really
enjoyable great storytelling context
behind him great context to the Mad Men
era so I think you really like this one
the flip side to this question was
what's the best way or the fastest way
to grow your email list well there is a
difference between quantity and quality
I think the fastest way to grow your
email list is to do a bunch of giveaways
okay that that is the fastest way to
grow your email list is to create a
giveaway in your Market that solves a
problem for the people you seek to serve
okay if like for me if I want to serve
copywriters one of my best giveaways is
copyrighting catalyst 63 cash cow tips
that you can read in 990 seconds or less
it's in the description if you don't
already have it go get it it's free okay
so that's a great way to get people on
your email list and solve a big problem
for them so a giveaway is a great way to
grow your email list it's honestly the
fastest way to grow your email list but
the caveat is a lot of times you get a
lot of people who are just looking for
freebies and they're not really looking
to be on your list or they don't really
care about you and so at that would I
would say it's not really the best way
to grow your email list it's just the
fastest way to grow your email list the
best way to grow your email list that
I've experienced is uh what is what is
called list swinging meaning I would
find somebody in your Niche that has a
quality list okay so like a copywriter I
would find somebody else who talks to
copywriters and I would ask them to do a
a shout out for shout out right we trade
shout outs hey I'll shout you out you
shout me out that doesn't really work if
he has a 10,000 list and I have a 1,000
list or vice versa or whatever it
doesn't work like that but if you can't
do a shout out for shout out you can
also pay for those spots and say hey can
we work agreed upon Ray 1,000 bucks 500
bucks 2,000 bucks whatever it is and
I'll advertise on your list and you get
a lot more subscribers that way list
swinging and cross promoting on list is
definitely the best way to get qualified
people who are already reading emails
who already care about that Niche and
who are already engaged in your stuff
and people like you why do you D asked
before you had an agency do you have any
tips on how to design or format your
email copyrighting portfolio also which
software websites have you use to build
your portfolio uh I'm not going to lie I
really don't use a portfolio other than
my daily email list like even work when
I do for clients they're off my list
right they read my emails which is kind
of crazy to say but at the end of the
day you are your portfolio so my writing
online and all that stuff like my
writing online and my writing via emails
that's my portfolio so when people read
my stuff they know I'm good like you
read it and you're like oh this guy's
good yeah I bet he could write bub yeah
totally right and so your email list is
your portfolio have clients chase you
not you chase them that's how you do it
the second part of the question being
which software websites have you used to
build your portfolio I've used uh almost
everything out there I would highly
recommend just being on WordPress okay
WordPress you could post all your stuff
it has all the Integrations like stop
diddly ding around I used to do like
Squarespace and card and all that stuff
bro just go on WordPress get sight
ground it's two bucks a month WordPress
is a plug it just do the work okay go to
Wordpress super super simple and then
convert kit is what I used to send on my
emails Alan Foley asks what's your least
favorite thing about what you do if you
had to pick one um I would say meetings
and maintenance I hate both of those
things I don't want to be in any
meetings with any people with which is
often times when I just focus on writing
for myself and things like that um and
maintenance if there's like if
something's broken if software needs to
be connected if I need to schedule all
my emails and schedule all my blog posts
and edit videos and bl all the
maintenance stuff I just want to create
stuff like I'm doing now and write my I
want to write my emails shoot some
videos all the things that are creative
and fun just like all of us right but at
the end of the day yeah meetings
maintenance Scott EP says when you have
an email marketing client how deep does
your service go do you write emails and
send them do you have access to their
clavo or whatever they use some people
say clavo I say cavia whatever okay um
and if you don't have direct access do
you simply rely on the client to give
you the analytics so here's my Pro if
I'm writing for a client it's basically
around this is I have one meeting with
them a month and it's about 60 to 90
minutes and I ask them questions stories
things that happen uh Goods bads worst
best things like that getting to know
them launches what things should I know
so I'm asking them a lot of questions I
usually record it on my phone and then I
export the recording to chat GPT to give
me the transcript and I say give me the
transcript and then summarize the
transcript and so it gives me all that
and then from there I write a bunch of
emails right and so whether it's three
emails a week or one email a week or
whatever the client is paying for and so
I'll write a bunch of emails in a Google
doc about a couple weeks ahead of time a
couple weeks before they need to to go
out and then I will send that Google doc
to the client and give them about 3 days
to review it revise it and send it to me
I give them a deadline otherwise they
teeter totter around and so from there
they can leave Google comments whatever
it is oh hey we actually sold 10 not 200
or whatever I don't know whatever it is
they leave comments I edit those things
and then I personally schedule it for
them so I have access to their convert
kit to their clayo to whatever and I
schedule everything for them I have
access to their analytics I export the
analytics and I actually set up an
automation to where their analytics
actually sends me a report in my email
once a week that says here's how many
emails went out open rates clickthrough
rates sales all that stuff and then I
have it generate a um week against last
week or mug to date or anything like
that to show how we've grown sales and I
send that to the client I honestly
automate a lot of the crap I don't want
to do and I really focus on the writing
and the relationship with the client so
it's not crazy deep but it is helpful to
them mvo asks what's the best way to
make your email subject lines
irresistible well I'm I have a different
video on this which is the five C's of
irresistible subject line so I'm glad
that you asked that but if I were to
lean into to one and I were to give you
one right now it's curiosity if you can
make your email subject lines curious
curiosity is the most powerful drug in
human psychology people will shake their
hands to click that thing if you can
make them curious enough like here's an
email subject line I used one time that
just took through the roof I did for a
farm that I was writing I wrote the one
food that replaces eight supplements
they're like what is this I mean that
market drooled over that one so yeah
curiosity Nick Hayes asked how did you
start copyrighting or how did you start
making money through it just Outreach to
random people so my copyrighting journey
is very backwards from everybody else
okay when I started copyrighting I
didn't even know it was called
copywriting if I'm being I was just
writing stuff and I started my own email
list and I started writing on Twitter
and I funneled those people from Twitter
to an email list and I was just teaching
them everything I knew about email
marketing and marketing because I have a
big background in marketing uh mainly
social media marketing advertising
Facebook ads um all those sorts of
things and I did email marketing
alongside those things but I never
called it copywriting I called it email
marketing and we'd write emails and we'
sell stuff right you create social posts
and you sell stuff right and so when I
got into the space I just did what I
knew best which was post on social media
move them to an email campaign and write
to them via email and over time I just
got so in love with the writing process
that I just focused solely on the
writing Less on the content Less on
social media and I just really wanted to
write and then I found the world of
copyrighting where I was like oh my gosh
there's a whole world of people like
doing this and it's like a thing and and
it's just so funny because when I was
sending emails not even knowing it was
copy I was still selling stuff so
monetizing you could sell your
copyrighting services to people it's not
what I did I went the other way I just
wrote for myself and sold my own stuff
like my book I have a book I sold that I
made a little course I sold that I had
some affiliate links for people who were
other selling their courses and their
writing products and their books I sold
that via my email list I did it all for
me and not for a client and oddly enough
I had a bunch of people who became
clients or friends or whatever asked me
to write for them so you know I did it
backwards I I can't say it's the right
way most people go after clients but
that's how my journey was Kristoff nth
asks this has been on my mind for a
while what's your opinion on non-native
people trying to become a copywriter
learning copywriting can these people
become good enough copywriters I would
like to think so but I don't see a lot
of them who do um so I have a very what
I would say controversial not fun
opinion on this and I do believe that if
you are a
non-native speaker I.E you don't speak
English as your native and primary
language I do think you're going to
struggle as an English copywriter I.E
writing into the English Market to sell
stuff to United States and and America
it's just because there's just such a
large gap there between the writing the
grammar the language the culture the
understanding it's so hard it's already
hard for native speaking people I mean I
know people who are born here including
myself who I mean we're busting our
freaking butts to get in it copyrighting
is really hard so I think if you're
non-native and you're trying to write in
your non-native language I think it's
going to be hard dang near impossible I
really do I hate saying that but I just
I barely seen native speaking English
people make it so it's definitely hard
the other way now I do think you could
write in your native language and write
copy in your native language and
obviously kick the butt out of everybody
which you should do U but non-natively
that's a struggle James Nicholson ask
grow in your newsletter here's a big one
I'm trying to work out at the moment
what was the time oh I'm sorry what was
the two is that how you wrote that what
was it to when you started writing the
newsletter and the amount of readers you
had I.E did you just start writing to
nobody and then sending it out when
people started subscribing or did you
wait until you had a certain number of
subscribers before you pulled the
trigger I hope this makes sense yeah
yeah basically do you start sooner or
later do you send to 10 people do you
wait till you have a 100 people whatever
it is I would start today okay I I what
I did was I started and I wrote to like
40 people for like 6 months yeah I mean
I text it was basically a friends and
family newsletter I texted some friends
and some family I said hey I'm writing
about oh gosh I don't even remember what
I started it with uh I'm writing about
this thing I think you would enjoy it I
send it out once a week I don't do that
I send a daily email out now but I write
about this thing and I send it out once
a week would you want to be on it here's
the link and I had 40 50 people
subscribe and that's all I have for the
longest time and then over time I found
really the thing I wanted to write about
email copyrighting in my Niche I'm
really centered into that and then I
started um connecting online and moving
people to my email list and I kept
emailing them so I would say yeah start
man because it's more about the craft of
writing than like I'm going to blow up
some big news bro just freaking write
write your stuff you're going to get
better you need to get better okay don't
sit here and wait till somebody gives
you permission you take permission and
then you go Crush the game you get them
on your newsletter and you freaking
write I'm so I'm sorry I got fired up
right there I just really want you to
write content all right that wraps us up
for today if you enjoyed the video like
And subscribe so I can continue to give
you content like this and again if you
haven't already grabbed it grab
copyrighting Catalyst it's in the
description below it's absolutely free
63 cash cow copyrighting tips for you to
enjoy and start making money immediately
I appreciate you being here I will catch
you on the next one that was a good one
I enjoyed those questions man man what
other question should I mean is there
any should we do a bonus question while
you guys are here this guy asked how do
you make the perfect bowl of spaghetti
I'm not going to answer that because I
don't know how to do it okay what other
what else what else is here that I
didn't answer